la lucha por la ciudad de bacmut no es
nueva esto Comenzó desde comienzos de
verano comienzos de Julio ya los ataques
se intensificaron pero en aquel momento
especialmente eran desde el aire con
misiles y con artillería esto se han
hecho mayor especialmente en los meses
de octubre y ahora en noviembre las
últimas semanas está siendo bastante
duro sin nos cuentan integrantes del
ejército ucraniano que están en este
momento en la ciudad donde nos
encontramos a 20 kilómetros a la entrada
de bakú donde muchos de ellos vienen a
hacer relevos y a tomar un respiro estos
ataques de las fuerzas rusas
Especialmente con divisiones que
intentan tomar la ciudad se han
intensificado en los últimos días dicen
aquí nos cuentan que la proporción es es
entre hombres es inmensa que por ejemplo
si hay 80 ucranianos pueden haber 300 o
300 50 soldados rusos pero dicen que la
diferencia es que mientras que los
ucranianos intentan conservar la vida de
sus compañeros las diferentes fuerzas
rusas que están allí no tienen ninguna
compasión con el resto de quienes
combaten y dicen que una de las escenas
más dramáticas en este momento en bacmut
es que hay muchos soldados todavía
tirados en la calle porque son
imposibles de recoger también nos dicen
que quedan civiles no muchos porque la
mayoría han partido en las últimas
semanas pero quienes están Viven en
subterráneos viven sin energía viven sin
agua viven sin abastecimiento porque no
hay mercados abiertos y también
desconectados del país porque no tienen
conexión a internet aquí hablando con
una mujer que salió hace pocos días de
vacuno cuenta que muchos de los que se
habían quedado lo habían hecho porque
estaban esperando que llegaran las
fuerzas rusas Pero ellos mismos se han
llevado una decepción porque sus casas
han quedado destruidas y han tenido que
salir también de la ciudad donde
continúa Pues esta batalla la más grande
que se vive en este momento no solamente
en el don vas sino en todo Ucrania